des bouleversements climatiques leurs
causes et leurs conséquences ne font pas
l'ombre d'un doute le consensus
scientifique est indéniablement solide
mais malgré l'épreuve accablante les
climato-sceptiques n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot loin de là une hyperactivité
des tenants de ce discours à même été
récemment observé sur les réseaux
sociaux un discours qui épouse de
nouvelles formes portées par un éventail
de plus en plus hétéroclite d'individus
avec l'ombre de l'industrie pétrolière
qui n'est jamais bien loin Valérie salue
bienvenue descripteurs parlons de ces
climato-sceptiques et de se regain de
vie de ce type de discours là qui existe
depuis un certain temps déjà toi tu le
constaté tu le constatais depuis un
certain temps mais il y a une étude du
CNRS du Centre national de recherche
scientifique en France qui est venu
accréditer cette thèse ouais en fait ils
ont évalué le volume de publication mais
aussi la teneur des propos contenus dans
ses publications là pour des milliers de
comptes Twitter et c'est comme ça qu'ils
ont constaté qu'il y avait une hausse de
l'activité des communautés
climatosceptiques donc qui partagent la
désinformation et qui nie en fait il y a
une crise climatique puis eux ce qu'on
remarqué c'est qu'à deux moments il y
avait eu une augmentation massive des
comptes climatosceptiques d'abord
pendant le premier cycle électoral
français qui s'est entamé au printemps
2022 et ensuite pendant la cop27 donc la
Conférence des Nations Unies sur les
changements climatiques qui a eu lieu en
Egypte en novembre dernier est-ce qu'on
pourrait poser l'étiquette anti-système
à ce type de personnes ou de groupe qui
animent ce genre de discours tout à fait
dans le fond les chercheurs ont
identifié que ce qui animait cette
communauté c'est un sentiment ce
sentiment antithème dont tu parles qui
serait là presque par principe ce qu'ils
ont remarqué c'est qu'il y a même pas
d'affiliation Corelli ni envers les
parties traditionnelles de droite ou de
gauche dans le fond c'est comme si le
climat était rendu leur cheval de
bataille mais c'est des internautes qui
ont été très beaucoup et très actifs sur
d'autres fronts par exemple les
chercheurs ont constaté que plus de la
moitié des contre-climatosceptiques
avaient déjà relayé de la propagande pro
Kremlin au début de la guerre en Ukraine
ou encore que certains profils avaient
diffusé des informations trompeuses sur
les variantes du coronavirus ou qui
s'était fermement opposé au monsieur
sanitaires pendant la pandémie de
covid-19 et ça c'est vrai pour la France
mais on a vu ça ailleurs dans le monde
aussi le fait que la pandémie a
cristallisée des communautés se sont
ralliés autour de croyances complotistes
et un autre aspect sur lequel les
chercheurs insistent ces clients un
caractère inothentique dans la
circulation de cette information encore
une fois autant en France qu'ailleurs
dans le monde ce sont des comptes qui
ont une tendance à diffuser des messages
potentiellement générés par des robots
et ces messages parlons-en qu'est-ce
qu'ils disent autour de quels axes sont
diffusés ces messages là ils sont très
habile ces internautes dans ce que les
chercheurs appellent la rhétorique des
5b qui manie de façon très très fluide
alors le premier d c'est pour la
déformation des faits scientifiques des
constats d'études un exemple qui
revenait souvent lorsque j'ai parlé à
des chercheurs c'est l'argument selon
lequel le CO2 c'est bon pour les plantes
donc plus il va y en avoir dans
l'atmosphère mieux se porteront les
écosystèmes c'est oui c'est des
publications que moi-même j'ai vu passer
sur mes réseaux sociaux
c'est un excellente exemple en fait
parce que on parle d'une étude qui nous
demande que le CO2 contribue à la
fertilisation des plantes mais on en
vient à dire que ce sera bon pour
l'environnement alors que le CO2 le
dioxyde de carbone c'est un gaz à effet
de serre qui contribue au réchauffement
climatique ensuite il y a le D pour
discrédit donc on va remettre en
question la crédibilité l'intégrité les
intentions des experts du climat donc
les scientifiques du GIEC un votre
décide celui de la distraction donc on
va rappeler au public que la crise
climatique c'est peut-être pas la plus
importante c'est peut-être pas le
dossier le plus
urgent en ce moment il y a des causes
plus importantes par exemple le chômage
donc ça ça revient beaucoup le quatrième
d c'est pour la dissuasion donc les
internautes vont mettre l'accent sur les
conséquences de ses politiques
climatiques vous allez voir on va perdre
des emplois on va restreindre vos droits
et libertés donc ce genre de discours là
le dernier D et pour la division qui
n'est pas le propre des communautés
climatosceptiques mais c'est une façon
de poser les puissants et le peuple donc
le peuple lui va subir de plein foi les
politiques climatiques tandis que
l'élite elle va s'en tirer indemne et
parmi les personnes qui propagent ce
type de messagerie il y a quand même des
figures de proue des personnes qui juste
en elle-même sont des gros facteurs de
propagation du discours
climato-sceptique oui dans une étude
britannique qui a été vous venez autour
des cops 26 et cop27 les chercheurs ont
fait des constats similaires à leurs
collègues français c'est-à-dire que ils
ont constaté qu'une poignée de compte
arrivée à un seul à avoir une visibilité
à susciter un engagement disproportionné
ce sont des super influenceurs on parle
de compte qui ont parfois plus d'un
million voire plusieurs millions
d'abonnés et qui vont utiliser leur
plateforme pour amplifier d'autres voix
qui tiennent des discours similaires un
exemple canadien qu'on peut donner c'est
celui de Jordan be Peterson ce
professeur émérite de l'Université de
Toronto qui s'est fait connaître pour
des positions controversées qui vont de
l'identité de genre à la censure
universitaire bon donc lui il ne parle
pas uniquement de climat mais si vous
allez voir ces pages si vous consultez
ces réseaux sociaux vous allez voir
qu'il va se plaindre par exemple de la
tyrannie des véhicules électriques puis
qui va éviter des personnalités sur sa
chaîne Youtube comme Alex epsteen qui
vendent vous les mérite des énergies
fossiles par exemple et à ça s'ajoute
aussi parmi cette panoplie cette
constellation d'acteurs certaines
organisations
dont les noms des lèvent aucun soupçon
mais en fait qui sont pilotés par
l'industrie pétrolière à une sorte de
similitantisme comme on dit de
d'arthroseurfing oui exactement donc ce
sera pas rare de voir des groupes se
présenter comme friends of silent c'est
une organisation canadienne qui est très
active sur Twitter et Facebook notamment
mais on sait que c'est une organisation
qui a déjà été financée par l'industrie
pétrolière et Gasia donc il faut se
méfier de ce type de nom qui peuvent
être trompeur il y a vraiment lieu de se
poser des questions Valérie sur à
travers tout ça là sur le rôle des
plateformes moins bains qui héberge ce
type de discours oui c'est qu'il crée un
lieu propice pour ceux qui ont le plus
d'argent pour véhiculer leur message et
là je pense ici à l'industrie pétrolière
ce ne sont pas juste des
des internautes climato-sceptiques qui
s'organisent à certains endroits dans le
monde non il y a vraiment un effort de
l'industrie pétrolière pour diffuser
cette désinformation sur les réseaux
sociaux aller chercheurs britanniques
ont évalué en 3 et 4 millions de dollars
américains la somme qui a été dépensée
par des entités liées aux énergies
fossiles sur Facebook et sur Instagram
pendant la cop27 donc les chercheurs en
appel à plus de responsabilité des gens
du web qui nous disent pourtant qu'ils
mettent en oeuvre des politiques pour
cesser endiguer le plus possible la
diffusion de ces messages là mais pour
ces constats de constater que ce n'est
pas le cas l'examen nous du monde qu'il
y a des faits dans les méta et Twitter
de ce monde
puisqu'il nous disent les chercheurs
c'est que si ces campagnes sur les
réseaux sociaux se poursuivent à ce
rythme là c'est rien de moins que les
processus démocratiques qui vont s'en
trouver affaibli d'où l'inquiétude qu'on
doit avoir face à ce type de phénomènes
qu'on comprend mieux désormais grâce à
tes explications merci beaucoup Valérie
pour ce passage au décrypteur merci
beaucoup à une prochaine